macht ihnen komplimente und gibt ihnen
das gefühl dass sie heiß sind
glaubt mir das funktioniert und das
wollen wir überprüfen und schicken den
sohn mexikanischer einwanderer auf
magath uhr
er kam mit der idee um die ecke dass es
ein kluger vorschlag wer einen
14-jährigen auf bagger tour zu schicken
herzlich kommt sollten wir heute endlich
ist es soweit nachdem auch mich die
allgemeine krankheit werde die durch
deutsche lande ist mitte september
erwischt hatte und jetzt die letzten
acht und neun tagen schnupfen hat sie
gerne zeit naseputzen war volle neben öl
mega fertig bin ich endlich auf dem weg
der genesung
das ist für euch leute dass sie ab jetzt
nicht mehr sagen meine videos klänge und
das natürlich selbstverständlich weiter
jeden zweiten tag ihres kommen denn das
gratis mein abo doch nicht immer jeden
zweiten tag auf einem kanal
vorbeischauen und heute habe ich nicht
gefunden was euch vermutlich ein kleines
bisschen trägern wird denn das video
anfang werden heißt der wohl jüngste
frauenversteher der welt und es geht um
einen 14-jährigen der denkt er wäre der
größte player der welt
hysterische geschrei junge mädchen
völlig außer sich am rande eines
nervenzusammenbruchs okay also da haben
wir schon unser übeltäter dieser typ
hier da auf der rechten seite ist
scheinbar der jüngste frauenversteher
der welt naja und falls ich fragte was
denn was ist eigentlich ein frauen zu
stärken kann ich mich selbstständig
sagen heute überhaupt keine ahnung was
dieser begriff bedeuten soll aber die
beschreibung verrät uns dass der mini
macho uns zu erklären versucht wie man
bei frau so richtig gut ankommt also
leute alle jungs da draußen jetzt ohren
spitzen wohl auch alle mädels immer gut
hinhören wenn
es gibt schon mal einiges zu lernen oder
wie ist eben fernandez dazu sagt ganz
normale alltag wenig auch sexy genug
ja du siehst nicht aus wie 8 oder so
also das jetzt auf keinen fall so wenn
jetzt irgend jemand da draußen wäre der
sagen würde dass du nicht wie ein model
aussiehst rechtlich den 14 jäger sondern
48 jähriger dann lass dir lass dir was
ihr von den leuten nichts einreden
du siehst aus wie ein model auf jeden
fall er ist amerikas heißesten äußern
der jäger ist der junge noch aufzuhalten
heute 14 sekunden individuelle der hat
eine wahrscheinlich softair-pistole
zusammen mit dem eis und flex damit
möchte von allen guten geistern verrat
gerade 14 und als babys comeback ein
echter internet star
denn in seinen videos erklärt stephen
wie man frau garantiert rumkriegt wird
so muss ich eine sache sagen heute okay
also dieses video auf youtube kanal ist
am 18 10 2014 erschienen also der typ
war scheinbar 2014 irgendwie so großen
honig auch irgendwann für euch was von
ihm gehört hat es diesem verein anders
sein
ich glaube auch schon wenn ich das video
2014 gesehen hätte hätte ich schon
eventuell meine vorbehalte gegen diesen
jungen mann gehabt aber jetzt ist es
fünf jahre später und die geschichte hat
noch mal ganz andere sachen über diesen
jungen aufgedeckt und darüber was er in
der zwischenzeit gemacht hat aber dazu
gleich mehr frauen stehen auf kerle mit
selbstbewusstsein so gut ich keine
schüsse sprich sie einfach an egal ob du
bescheuert aussieht ist ich sehe ständig
bescheuert aus bisschen komisch vor
jetzt einen 14-jährigen zu business für
seine modischen entscheidung aber diese
hello kitty bettwäsche trotzdem reißen
sich die mädels geradezu um ihnen
inzwischen herrscht in den teams kälter
aus als ein echter hype 72 gemeinde im
netz wächst unaufhörlich also kurze
frage an der stelle also der video titel
war ja wohl
jüngste frauenversteher der welt warum
sehen wir in diesem video nur 13 jährige
mir das nichts gegen der gewährleistung
geben man hat über 13 allem am anfang
der pubertät wurden von der pubertät
erwischt sie von einem baseballschläger
mitten ins gesicht ok und haben unsere
jahren war fraglos oben bis unten aber
wie erklärt jetzt irgendwelche
30-jährigen oder so das ist jetzt
irgendwie bisschen enttäuschend so was
erlebe ich eigentlich ständig ich muss
nur auf die straße laufen und vier fünf
mädels beginnen zu scheinen ich frage
dann was ist los wie so schreit ihr es
ist verdreckt also lotterie tor diese
ganze sache so wird ich habe meine
artikel zu diesem typen durchgelesen ok
alles klar der typ kommt aus konnten das
ist ein vorort von los angeles in den
vereinigten staaten und eine richtig
harte gegenwehr kommt auf so richtig
krachen gegen muss man sagen wir gehen
deswegen post an ihnen dass er ist da
raus geschafft hat irgendwie ins
gewissen bekannt jetzt aber die sache
ist er ist auch damit bekannt geworden
dass er irgendwie video auf seinem
youtube kanal so hochgeladen hat wo er
einfach also mädels auf der straße
einfach belästigt hat und die folge
kratzert und das sogenannte pick up
girls legende descartes und ja dass ich
will auch nicht ein bild von ihm so ins
zerstören aber es gab eben so
ermittlungen von der polizei gegen den
weil er irgendwie als er 15 war
irgendwas mit einer 12 jährigen hatte
bereits mit 9 wird der talentierte
skateboarder entdeckt und model für
erste skater clips dass sich minister
amin azeti warum kann sich dieser
kindergarten geflüchtete nicht einmal
normal verhalten wie so fahren die
mindest vermutlich liegt an seinem
schrägen humor den tipps die inzwischen
halb amerika begeistern
wobei ich weiß heute nicht was ich weiß
ich hab es mir irgendwie ein bisschen
daraufhin gespielt so ich habe es
irgendwie aufgefordert ihm gesagt haben
endlich frauenversteher aber henkel
sowie 13 jährigen droht die frau sei
aber doppelt so ein machte ihnen
komplimente und gibt ihnen das gefühl
dass sie heißen klaut mir das
funktioniert und das wollen wir
überprüfen und schicken den sohn
mexikanischer einwanderer auf magath uhr
also sollte ich will auch mit der
tradition auch wieder top nation nicht
zu hart ins gericht gehen aber wer kampf
mit der idee um die ecke dass es ein
kluger vorschlag wer einen 14-jährigen
auf bagger tour zu schicken
da muss man sie vergeben heute okay also
ein deutsches fernsehteam trifft sich in
wahrscheinlich los angeles oder model
kalifornien mit einem 14-jährigen und
schickt ihn los und frauen zu haben ich
hab keinen bock motiven auf der jagd
nach telefonnummern seien ultimativer
flirter volk könnt ihr mich fahren
kannst du deine nummer in meine telefon
speichern
weil super richtig ist wofür falls dies
hätten möchtest es ist so ist das deine
maske geht so auf ältere mädels oder
älter frauen so ist dann so das
überzeugt mich ich werde dich okay gut
dass die cops für dich ist alles okay du
hast hat sich ihre nummer bekommen
sie hat sich darauf eingelassen dass sie
dich babysitter sehr gut
habe ich was passieren würde wenn ich
das machen würde ich doch so durch die
innenstadt und wächst also jung bist du
mich babysitter
das verstehe ich meine idee oder mehr
als stern drauf wenn man aufrichtig und
offen lässt solange du ihnen damit keine
angst machst okay okay du hast ja also
ich bin weil ich bin aufrichtig und
ehrlich diskutiert eine frage an der
stelle was das wieder aufreißen leicht
gemacht und dann können es 14 jährigen
der weiß wie man bei frauen ankommt ich
spiele nicht die sache ist auch etwas
für sie zögert bei dieser ganzen sache
alle ist führt seine sieht er aus 14
retov also wenn mich jemand fragen würde
so schmal wie alte junge sozusagen als
vielleicht ist das das muss auch so sein
für die babysitter strategie keine frage
man kann von stevens tipps halten was
man will aber der erfolg gibt dem
rotzlöffel recht
so und jetzt brauche ich noch eure
telefonnummer da ist es natürlich mit
abstand schwierigste part von den
eigenen fans
was wirklich menschen sind die
einfachsten okay du hast deine
abgrundtief niemand auf der welt mag ein
so wenig wie die eigenen fans
dementsprechend ist natürlich auch am
schwersten von denen nummer zu bekommen
also blieben einfach an der stelle
nochmals von ganzem herzen was du heute
soll die ganze scheiße leute ich würde
sagen wenn ihr beim anschauen dieses
videos allein durch zu sehen von steven
aufgerissen wurde dann schreibt mir das
gerne in die kommentare
wenn ihr mich babysitten wollt schreibt
mir das auch gerne in die kommentare
ansonsten für einen normalen menschen
draußen könnt ihr vorgeschlagen sich
auch chicken junge klavier das was mir
so weit heute der wohl jüngste frauen
missverstehe aller zeiten macht's gut so
und damit dieses video noch die zehn
minuten erreicht und sebastian seine 13
kinder versorgen kann habe ich ein witz
für euch
was waren die letzten worte des turm
springers
das wasser ist heute aber schön klar
hahaha
oh mein gott ich bin der lustigste
roboter der welt